day one of the five day pause and ccsd
may be over but some parents may still
be trying to figure out what to do with
their kids next week well that's why a
pop-up art camp is opening in the
southwest part of the valley victoria
saha has more
so cute we make like dresses with
different techniques and maybe some
accessories eva gotoff comes to art
class at bash and design after school
but on monday she will be spending her
whole day here as the school district
continues its pause i really do like
school and
kind of sad to not see my friends for
five days but then you come here and
then how do you feel then i felt amazed
and
epic for fifty dollars the art studio is
hosting an all-day art camp on monday to
keep students engaged they get to
work with different materials such as
recycling art so we show them how to
give second life
to things and then they'll be working
with clay
paint on canvas we provide snacks and
everything having a sudden pause on
their school week is causing some stress
for students but parents say coming to
an all-day art camp will be good for
their mental health kids are frustrated
they're exhausted which is why working
parents like yana gotov are grateful for
this unique camp instead of kids sitting
on gadgets all day long they can come
and do some creations here i feel that
this monday is more than ever it's
probably going to help everybody making
a difference with every piece of art
victoria saha live local now
and we do have information on how to
sign up post it to 8newsnow.com you can
choose a morning afternoon or even an
all-day option